hello hi and welcome to today's
presentation I can see a couple of you
have started to come into the room hi
can I ask you if you've got a video on
just to make sure that you've turned
your video off so that's great
we're just going to give people a couple
more minutes to enter the room and so if
I could ask you all at the bottom of
your screens as you know there's a chat
box can you just let us know where
you're located where are you dining him
from hopefully you can all see that my
colleague mira career coach mira is also
online she's in the chat room we're just
going to give people another two minutes
to join a couple people still entering
the room okay can you let me know if you
can all hear me okay
can you all see the chat box can you all
access it great hi hi Ibrahim hi Susan
perfect
great Magdy from germany hi okay we're
going to give it another two minutes
before we get started okay what's the
weather like where you all are today so
here I'm based in London it's a water
sleeting almost snowing earlier but much
drier now hey Egypt ah snowing in
Germany yes I I guess it's perfect
weather in Egypt lovely okay guys we're
gonna give it just probably one more
minute and then I will let us get
started okay
so we'll probably have some late joiners
so we'll just as they come we'll just
get them to be admitted to the room okay
everyone so let's get started
hi everyone for those of you who don't
know me my name is Jackie Lawrence I'm
one of the career coaches at Udacity
today we are going to be talking about
culture fit identifying your core values
and aligning them with your career just
to give you a few minutes I'll talk to
you for a few minutes about the
structure of today's session I'm gonna
talk for about 45 minutes on the topic
and then there will be time for Q&A s
I'm going to keep everyone muted to
avoid background noise as we go along if
you have any questions please type them
in the chat box I also have with me my
co-host career coach Mira
she's here to assist me with managing
this webinar and the chat box so let's
get started a little background about me
so as I mentioned to you before I'm a
career coach at Udacity but I'm also a
business strategy and development coach
from a business strategy perspective I
help individuals and organizations to
unlock barriers to growth and
development so that they can move
towards achieving their business and
policy goals from a career perspective I
help students I help professionals who
are looking to transition or who are
just looking at exploring options of
where they can go next so without
further ado why don't we move on to
today's agenda and we're just going to
take you through that so what's on the
topic what's on the list so today's
agenda consists of what our core values
we're going to do a value exercise what
is cultural fit we're going to look at
defining it and what it actually means
researching and assessing an
organization's culture will then look at
the importance of lining core values
with business culture how to show
cultural fit in an interview and then
we'll move on to Q&A
so moving on to the next slide we are
going to do a poll and so just to let
you know this poll is anonymous so I
want you all should just have a little
think back at places where you've worked
and have a think have you ever worked
for a company where you felt that you
really fit in so it's that gut feeling
where when you're somewhere you can be
your authentic self you don't need to
pretend that you're someone else you're
just being you so I'm just about to
launch this poll and I want you to think
about this question have you ever worked
for a company where you felt that you
really fit in yes no or maybe you're not
sure okay and here goes okay so I'm
gonna give you guys about a minute to
answer okay interesting
ah that is interesting what's your gut
instinct tell you did you really feel
authentic so that's interesting okay I'm
gonna give it another 30 seconds waiting
for that one more votes come in
oK you've got 80% there can we move it
up a notch
okay I'm going to get ready to end the
poll results are interesting okay two
more seconds okay we're going to end the
poll and the poll results are in so have
you ever worked for a company where you
felt that you really fit in 50% of you
said yes no were 25% an unsure 25% so
that's a very sort of balanced view 50%
of you have had that experience and it's
great when you actually feel that you
fit into an organisation and the thing
is sometimes you don't actually really
appreciate it or realize it until you
move on you don't actually realize how
well you fit into that organization so
now that we've got our first poll done
let's move on to our next slide so we're
going to take a look now our what our
core values
well our values define what is most
important to us they form our beliefs
help us how to define how we perceive
things the choices we make our actions
and the behaviors we show not all values
are equal we prioritize them under
pressure
some values Trump or force our other
values if two of your values for example
may include stability and challenge but
there are some instances where you feel
the timing isn't right to challenge you
will then prioritize stability over
challenge our values also change over
time as we attain goals and our views
and understanding so I think looking at
values we are now going to move on to
the next one identifying your core
values so how do you identify your core
values some of you may have tried to do
this some of you have may never have
really thought deeply about your values
so values can be categorized into
different headings you have family
values career values societal values for
the purpose of this webinar we're going
focus on career values career values can
be subdivided into three further
categories we'll call these intrinsic
values so these are intangible rewards
that keep you motivated in your job why
you get up and you go to work and
engaged you then have extrinsic values
these are linked to the conditions you
find at work such as the office
environment and earning potential then
there are lifestyle values these are
more closely linked to your personal
values they're associated with where you
want to live and your lifetime goals
moving on to our next slide so we now
have another poll this was our second
poll and the poll question is have you
ever completed a values exercise so you
may have done one recently so you may
answer yes you may have done one but
it's been a while since you last did one
and like I say value change or no so I'm
about to launch this poll now so have a
little think may launch button okay
getting ready to do the second poll here
goes so again thinking about what you've
been doing in the past and your job
search strategy have you ever completed
a values exercise okay interesting
okay the polls are changing yes yes but
it's been a while now okay
perfect we currently have a hundred
percent already great so I'm going to
end the poll I know you know so what's
the answer yes recently so that's only
20 percent of you 40 percent of you have
actually carried out a values exercise
but it's been a while since you lasted
one and again forty percent no and it's
great for the 20 percent of you who have
done one recently so that should help
you be more focused and strategic with
your job strategy search for those of
you who've done it a while ago you might
want to think about doing it again
because as they say values change over
time and for those of you who have never
done one well after the end of this
webinar you might think about doing one
so let me just close that poll so moving
on to our next slide here you're gonna
see a list of core values and there's
about a hundred values listed here but
value lists can come you know you can
get about 220 words on a values it
really just depends on you and the whole
point of having this core value list is
to allow you to be able to have a look
through and pick out certain words that
resonate with you your values so for
some of you balance might be one of your
values service might be one of your
values strengths the whole point of
looking at your core values is to
identify about ten values which you
would consider your top ten values and
then try and reduce this down to five
because if you have too many values it
can become quite overwhelming the point
of it is then once you pick out what
values me most to you
define what it means to you so loyalty
might be one of your values but how you
define loyalty and how someone else
defines loyalty in a career context may
be different and so there will be times
when you're in your career and even your
job search where these values will
compete with each other and so it's not
just about picking out the values that
resonate with you but it's also about
putting them in an order or priority so
there
when there's a conflict you can think
about which value Trump's which other
value so I thought it'd be helpful if we
have a go at actually doing a values
exercise so the next couple of slides
we'll take it through a values exercise
now there are lots of values exercises
out there you don't have to do this
particular one and you know if you're
interested I can share afterwards in
student hub a couple of exercises that
you can do yourself online they're
totally free you don't have to pay for
them but it's a good way of checking in
with your staff as to whether your
values are the same or whether they've
moved on so let's take a look at this
core values exercise so identifying your
values let's have a look we're going to
start off by this looking at intrinsic
values so like I said before intrinsic
values are those values where you have
intangible rewards that keep you
motivated and engaged at your job
so here below you're going to see a list
of five intrinsic values and what I want
you to have a go at doing is on a scale
of one to five with five being the most
important right how important these
intrinsic values are to you so for the
purpose of today and you know because it
takes a bit of time to do this all I'm
going to do is I'm going to ask you to
sort of have a look at these values so
number one having variety and change at
work some of you may get bored doing the
same task each day whilst others may
prefer a set routine helping others so
that's like working for a company with a
good cause one that gets back to society
some people find that very very key and
important they want to feel that they're
working somewhere where society values
or benefits from it the next factor is
feeling respected at work so a survey by
the Society of the human resource
management found that 65% of all workers
said that respectful treatment of all
employees is an important factor of job
satisfaction taking risk or use someone
that seats constant thrill and
excitement at work or are you more risk
averse having your work
recognize receiving public recognition
from those higher up in the organization
is a key priority for many people so
what I'd like you to have a go at doing
now is just type in the chat bot which
of the above you would rank as number 5
so remember number 5 is the most
important to you which ranks as number 5
or you might want to put what rank which
one ranks as number 1 so which of these
intrinsic values are least important to
you so I'm just gonna give you a moment
to tap that in have a little look have a
little thing and then just tap in you
might just put taking risk 5 or you
might put taking risk 1 or depends so
I'd just like to know your thoughts on
this and what you'll probably find is
deep put different people have totally
different priorities different ways of
thinking as to what's important to you
so remember number 1 might be having
variety and change at work is that a
priority for you is that key do you get
bored with the same task each day is
helping others a key priority to you
feeling respected at work taking risks
having your work recognized okay coming
in 5 helping others 1 taking risk yep so
that's quite interesting so 5 some
people survive is the most important ok
great thank you for that okay so we've
got another two exercises to do so what
I'm gonna do at seasons come through
again a 5 having variety 1 having your
work recognized mmm feeling respected at
work top priority yeah a lot of people
resonate with that having variety and
change yeah that's quite quite important
for people as well that's great thanks
very much for your contributions on
intrinsic values so why don't we take a
look at the second factor like I said we
can break career values down into three
segments so the next segment we're going
to look at is extrinsic values so these
are linked to the conditions you find at
work
such as your office environment vacation
policy and earning potential is there a
career development path again on a scale
of one to five with five being the most
important I'm going to ask you to rank
how important are these I should say
extrinsic values to you
so one traveling to work or traveling
for work rather so some people might
think it's very exotic to be able to get
on a plane and to be traveling around or
to be traveling around your country
quite regularly some people that doesn't
really appeal to them getting a high
salary how important is that to you what
about the amount of vacation leave you
can take so when I worked in the
corporate world we had the ability to
buy like an extra five or six days
holiday of course it came out of your
salary and and so for some people they
would buy six days additional salary for
them at six days additional vacation for
them it was worth compensating the loss
of their salary or a lower salary for
the additional vacation II setting your
own hours this has been ranked by
employees as one of the most important
factors for job satisfaction having
autonomy at work some of you may find
micromanagement unbearable so you know
when you've got that boss or that person
who constantly looks older you over your
shoulder so again let's have a think
about what's the most important here
with five being the most important and
which one of these extrinsic values is
the least important to you so you drank
that as one traveling for work is it a
perp or a drain getting a high salary
amount of vacation leave you can take
setting your own hours or having
autonomy at work let us know your
thoughts okay
just again in the chat box they have
autonomy at work traveling for work
number one yeah a lot of people in the
beginning it might be really exciting
right after a while it can become a
drain setting your own hours and getting
a high salary yep often the two can and
I will tee up with each other oh you
know getting a salary high salary for
some people may be number one they're
not so bothered about having a high
salary might be more important about the
environment they work in yep five
setting your own hours yeah there's a
lot of little like-minded people on here
in terms of their extrinsic values
that's great ah yes a comment from my
co-host so yes this is also a way for
negotiations many students often ask
okay so my co-host Mira has just
mentioned a comment here but this is
also a way of negotiations when you
students often ask how do we get better
salaries yeah and you can and it's a
good point actually mirror you know you
can often um compensate for things well
you can often trade things in you know
it's funny this week I was having a talk
with someone and they really liked a job
but the problem was the travel was a lot
further than what they were previously
having to do in terms of commuting to
work and you know one of the things that
we discussed about possibly trading off
is whether it was possible for that
individual to work from home and
additional day awake so you know think
about you know points that you can
negotiate can you ask for non-cash
benefits you know these are key things
you might decide that actually if I can
work from home two days a week maybe
that you know taking that job with that
extra half hour drive isn't so bad or
extra half hour can you it's all about
you know what benefits you and thinking
about your values and the order of
priority and then using that as a tactic
your negotiation okay so we're going to
move on to the last values exercise so
we've looked at intrinsic values
extrinsic values and now we're going to
look at lifestyle values so these are
the personal values associated where you
want to live how you spend your free
time and your long-term goals again
we're going to look at them on a scale
of one to five with again five being the
most important to you and one being the
least important to you so spending time
with friends and family this goes back
to work life balance a job of long hours
impact with family time so obviously if
you're at work for long periods of time
it means you have less time to spend
with your friends at less time to spend
with your families living in a big city
some people thrive in a big city some
people don't like the hustle and bustle
of a big city and prefer to work in
quieter towns living abroad some people
are quite happy to move abroad to pursue
their dream jobs some people feel that
their ties or their family ties or their
friends or other things they feel more
tied to where they currently live so
they wouldn't consider moving abroad for
a dream job as a prospect for them it's
just not a value that they really rank
highly saving money so if you're saving
for a home this may be a critical value
for you and again becoming a home owner
so again in the chat box type you know
your preferences watch your priority
number five being your most important is
it spending time with friends or family
or is it saving money what's your lowest
priority or what's your lowest value
let's have a look and see what your
thoughts are spending time with family
and friends yes that's coming in at
number five a couple of you yeah
becoming a homeowner not such a key
thing at the moment and that's fair
enough living in a big city number one
yeah you know for some of you that may
just not be an important value when it
comes to your values as a priority it
may not really factor honey on your list
it's not such a big issue so that's
great
okay let's just move on to the next
slide and this is just wrapping it all
up in one so the idea is once you've
completed all three sections you look at
the values that you have rated five so
these are your top priorities these are
your going to be your top priorities and
then you'll look at those values that
you've listed as fours and threes now
these are still going to be important to
you but they just shouldn't be at the
top of your list of search criteria when
you're searching for your next job next
determine which of the three categories
so whoever is intrinsic extrinsic or
lifestyle values is most important to
you and then think about do any of the
values within these categories overlap
so work-life balance spending time with
friends and family some of these values
do in a way overlap your objective is to
figure out what your top five to ten
values are like I said before there are
many values that might appeal to you but
if you have too many values it's just
going to feel overwhelming when you're
trying to decide the priority in any
order and which values you should take
into consideration when you're carrying
out your job search strategy so once
you've identified these values your
crucial your critical top 5 to 10 think
about ways that these values could be
reflected in your I'll do your job and
this is where you need to take time to
sit down and you write down what these
words are what these values are
but define personally what do they mean
to you what do these values mean to you
and that's going to take a bit of time
and reflection and it's not something
that you necessarily have to do on your
own you can start it off on your own but
if you want to talk through any when you
exercise results you can always book a
one-to-one session with a career coach
and you know we can take time sit down
and go through your values and talk
about why our values ranks over another
value on what's really critically
important for you as a value when you're
doing a job search ok and let's move on
to our next slide so now I just want you
to share your thoughts
do you take Bailey
into account when job searching so think
about you know past job searches how
you've got your current role if you're
currently in a job did you or do you now
take your values into account when job
searching let's know your thoughts be
interesting to see how many of you do
any views any views for those of you
who've already carried out value
exercises have you actually thought
about using it using those top values as
parts of your you know your job search
or you know bringing those values to
work in your day to day job and you may
not have thought about it it may not be
something that you've really thought you
need to do or why should you and
hopefully by the end of this webinar you
will understand the importance of
actually you know identifying your core
values and taking them with you to work
so let's just move on again like I say
you know culture fit now it's what we're
going to move on to and you know what is
it what is it people hear this word
culture fit a lot so it's basically
matching people with business culture so
an organization's culture consists of an
organization shared values they're
symbols behaviors and assumptions I like
the way Edgar Schein who's a leading
expert on culture defines it he defines
it as simply put organization culture is
the way we do things around here great
culture fear is based on a fact that an
employee who feels connected to the
values of the business and cliques
naturally with the nuances is more
likely to thrive business culture varies
from organization to organization so
many of you who may have worked in a
couple of roles may have found that
actually depending on where you want the
culture just the feel and the
environment and the people you work with
are very very different one study found
that 84% of recruiters surveyed agreed
that cultural fear is one of the most
important improvement factors so let's
look at
searching and assessing and an
organization's culture so we're going to
turn to the next slide now so what does
it actually involve well know your
values before you can actually bring
values into researching and assessing an
organization's culture you need to
understand your own values so you're
looking for is is an organization's
culture a right fit for you
so research when you're doing your
research use your top values as a filter
when looking at a job description that
appeals to you go through that and think
why is it that it appeals to me does it
connect and identify with my values when
you're looking at company then you're
looking for their values search the
company's websites look at their mission
statement look at their about Us page
what does it say about the company what
is the company telling you about
themselves look at company reports
company reports often give you further
information such as the demographics of
employees turnover rates benefits health
care again on LinkedIn many of your
target companies may have LinkedIn pages
so follow your target company on
LinkedIn or any blogs that they produce
what you're looking to do is to start
building a picture of what this company
is like so moving onto the next slide
there were just two more points that you
can include as part of your search
networking talk to people in your
network to connect with people or
connect with people on LinkedIn who may
have worked or are currently working at
your target company you know the best
way to find out about a company is
really from someone on the inside also
remember to use tools like glass door
you can use glass door to check for
companies reviews employees often go on
to glass door and they will live with
leave reviews about their companies
talking about sometimes they talk about
whether they think the benefits good
salaries are good whether the people are
great to work with
so glass tour can really be a helpful
tool and in terms of giving you a bit of
background history and information
from people who are either working at
the company or who have worked at the
company in the past so let's move on to
our next slide so I thought what might
be helpful is to look at an example of a
corporates values and so here we've got
called Google score values and some of
you may have looked at Google's values
already for those of you who may have
applied to Google but here is an example
of what Google's core values are so they
say they focus on the user and all else
will follow it's best to do one thing
really really well fast is better than
slow democracy on the web works you
don't need to be at your desk to need an
answer you can make money without doing
evil there's always more information out
there the need for information crossed
all ballers you can be serious without a
suit and great just isn't good enough
and then what's really good about
companies like Google is that you can
actually go into Google's philosophy
page and you will find that they not
only list their core values but they
also provide examples so they break it
down to another level they actually tell
you and defines you what their core
value means so for example their core
value great just isn't good enough in
that value they expand on what this core
value means in practice they state we
see being great as something as a
starting point not an endpoint we set
ourselves goals we know we can't reach
here because we know that by stretching
to meet them we can get further than we
expected so you know if you are a goal
orientated innovative person you will
probably resonate with that
so if innovation is one of your values
and your top values this is something
that might resonate with you and then
they give an example they say for when
for example when one of our engineers
saw that search worked well for properly
spelled words he wondered about how it
handled typos that led him to create an
intuitive or more helpful spell checker
and what that actually told you about
Google is they actually take their
employees ideas and views into account
and that can be very important for
people joining a company are you a voice
that is heard will your voice and your
ideas and your thoughts be heard so
that's just an idea of one company but
of course as you do your searches I'd
encourage you to go on to companies
websites look at their talk about me or
about Me section just to find out more
about what their core values are so
moving on to our next slide an important
factor something that sometimes people
don't realize until they arrive at a
company and they're already in the role
and by which time it's a bit too late
and so it's finding out and considering
whether a company may have a negative
culture so here are a couple of signs
that a company may have a negative
culture as you know every company
culture is unique and I'll say you get
great company cultures and if you have a
great company culture that company
culture is heard and fell and just so if
you have a bad one a company culture
with a bad or poor company culture can
create a negative impact and can lead to
large staff turnover or overall failure
if the problematic issues are not
addressed when you're in a great culture
you'll find that it will encourage
growth ownership and there will be an
environment and trust an open
communication with its employees so
let's have a little look at what are the
signs of a negative company culture poor
internal communication for example there
may be a lack of team spirit
micromanagement
that's that feeling that you're being
under constant scrutiny this can create
an atmosphere of fear in the
organization and make employees feel
under unnecessary pressure focus on
profit now you know it's always good and
you know you expect companies to want to
insure that they have good quarterly
results that's very important but if a
company is solely focusing on this and
leaving no room for employee engagement
that can be detrimental
no office engagement is there much
engagement is there much engagement
between the employees or what the
manager tells the employees before an
announcement is made a significant
announcement for example is there a lack
of empathy you know if there is you're
ill and you have to take time off work
are you pressured to come back before
you need to is there a poor management
or leadership style do you feel that you
can go to your managers your manager
approachable do they have your backing
or your corner is there a higher staff
turnover and this loss often a critical
thing to look out for if you find that
people are not staying in an
organization for more than a year why is
that why can they not retain colleagues
for a long time or employees for a long
time but on the converse you can say
well people have been there for 10 15 20
years is that a good thing think about
it does that mean that through a lot of
people who might be set in their ways so
you know you need to sort of think about
the balance and what it might mean and
an organization where your ideas are not
taken into consideration and I mentioned
this before because for some people for
some of you it may be key that your
thought process your thinking and your
ideas are at least heard you don't want
to be dismissed or overridden all the
time whenever you mention something and
you try to contribute no flexibility so
in this day and age obviously where
we've got technology and there's no
reason in many instances why people
can't work from home if there's no
flexibility you have to be in five days
a week you may have an off day or you
may have something important that's
wrong at home and so you may want to
work from home that day and if there's
no flexibility about it you might want
to consider whether you want to work in
that type of environment bad reputation
and you know that's the whole point of
doing your research when a company is
good and has an excellent culture word
gets out and in the same way when a
company has a poor or bad culture word
also gets out so keep your ears and your
awareness to the ground you know be
aware of this company its dealings with
other companies its dealings with its
employees the bottom line is do your
research so let's move on to the next
slide and this is again share your
thoughts so have you experienced working
in a company with a negative corporate
culture I'd be interested to know just
let us know your thoughts maybe you have
it maybe this is something you've never
experienced but if you have just let us
know yeah any experience with working in
a company with your negative corporate
culture not sure yeah
for management and leadership style hmm
yeah and unfortunately it doesn't leave
you with a very positive feeling it can
actually is really sort of then your
self-esteem you know when you're when
you're sort of in that environment so
yeah fortunately a couple of you have
actually experienced it so thanks for
sharing that okay so like I say let's
look at the next slide so why is it
important to align your core values with
your business culture what's important
what does it matter
really so let's look at it from both the
employer and the employee perspective so
let's think about given the amount of
time that you spend in the workplace
especially for those of you who are
looking for full-time work or who are
working full-time you know you're giving
approximately 40 hours a week if not
more to this particular business so
you're going to be spending a lot of
time there so it's important that you
feel happy and you feel connected to
where you were when core values are out
of alignment with business values the
employee lacks job satisfaction and is
more likely to leave from an employee's
perspective they're concerned about
culture fit because when you know the
employee and the employers cultures are
out of alignment
you're more they are more likely to face
staff retention issues absenteeism and
absenteeism cost on both sides so you
know if they can't retain staff it means
that they
to spend a lot of money on again getting
somebody else in training the month so
there's a cost to a business if their
culture fit is not right
again absenteeism so when we have
colleagues who always somebody has to
pick up the workload right so that work
then gets shared among other colleagues
and sometimes if you're stretched and
you're over stretch the last thing you
want is to have to be picking up other
people's wear so these are things that
you know it really is critical to get
culture fit right engagement if the fit
is right it's more likely as an employee
to be fully committed and go above and
beyond what is required so for those of
you who said that you've experienced
being in a place where you really fit in
you know the work and the hours may be
long but because you really thought you
fit in and you enjoyed your time at the
end of the organization you may not have
minded committing to such long hours and
you know really putting yourself out
there when needed and for businesses
they really really look for this you
know this level of engagement is really
critical for a business's success so
again moving on to looking at a couple
couple more points as to why it's
important to align core values with
business culture and the next slide
productivity so companies with employees
who believe in the goals and values of
the organization tend to be more
productive you know if you're in an
environment where you feel you fit you
just feel that you can actually work to
the best of your abilities you know if
you don't feel aligned your productivity
is going to be impacted and poor
productivity again leads to more staff
retention issues and again will lead to
more absenteeism communication there's
more likely to be fully committed and
going above and beyond if there's good
clear transparent communication do those
higher up you know are they clear and
transparent about what's going on in
your organization particularly when it
comes to change change management's when
there are reorganizations going on
cohesion a team that works together with
the same core values functions better
now this is no
about companies hiring clothes yeah you
know when it comes to cultural fit
diversity is still important but the
thing with cultural fit is you may have
somebody who's it's very senior very
mature in age with you know a family of
three versus a young millennial who's
quite fresh and maybe just new into the
career working at the same organization
now whilst on the surface when you look
at them you may think gosh they're at
two different ends of the spectrum there
will be a certain amount or qualities or
traits that they share you know and
these characteristic is what makes the
team fear and what then identified than
aligns with the company's values and
together creates a good culture of it
communication again collaborative
working processes open communication so
these are things and factors that you
know companies think about when they're
taking employees on in their hiring for
culture fear so thinking about that why
it's important to ensure that our values
align with our career let's think about
it in terms of the job strategy process
and when you're actually going for an
interview so moving on to our next slide
onto how to show cultural fit in an
interview so you put all your hard work
so you've got your applications
community documents in everything's down
to a tee and you get to the interview
stage one of the key factors that the
company will be evaluating is whether
you are a right match for the company
now this is often one of the main
reasons why candidates do not get a job
remember the interview process works two
ways if the candidates opportunity to
assess whether they think the role and
the company is a right fit for them and
vice versa also the interview starts
from the time you arrive at the
interview site all the company's offices
from your perspective from the time you
arrive at the company's office be
observant what's the office environment
like what the receptionist like are they
stress is there lots of paper on their
desks are there many people on site how
are people working
are they working in silo or are there
pods on Huddle's when you're going
through the interview and you get you
know to the ton to the time at the end
of the interview use that time when they
asked you have any questions you want to
ask use it as an opportunity to find out
more about the company's culture you
might want to ask them questions such as
what activities do your team do for fun
you may want to be a bit more direct and
just ask them tell me about your office
culture from an employer's perspective
they are looking to understand who you
are as an individual what drives you
what motivates you and what D motivates
you what atmosphere do you prefer so
I've just listed a couple of examples of
cultural fit interview questions tell me
about yourself now that's quite a wide
question but from that an employer can
elicit what's important to you so when
you're talking about tell me about
yourself use it as an opportunity to
interweave your values what are your
critical values when you're describing
what's important to you and talking
about yourself weave that into the
question another question that may come
up is describe the type of work
environment in which you can give your
best so for example if you're
interviewing at a start-up and you
realize that you're highly independent
self motivated and you excel at working
at a fast pace you'll want to
proactively highlight this and all those
factors in your answer however if you're
someone who likes to take your time to
understand something before you actually
hear a start-up may not be the right
environment for you if you're used to
for example working in a quiet office
with two or three people in a room and
the company has a large open plan office
with lots of background noise you may
not be able to function at your best and
some of you may have you know experience
working in these different dynamics I
know that I have and I remember going
for an office where there is sort of two
and three of us in it and it was quite
quiet at time to being in an environment
where there were like a hundred people
on the floor in an open environment and
it really is quite an adaptation that
you have to make
so also think about the question when
they ask you do you prefer working alone
or as part of a team another way they
might ask this question is tell me about
a team project you did at work what was
the project what was your role on what
was the outcome
so the candidates response will help the
employer to determine whether they like
being part of the team also their
attitude do they blame others for
failures or take responsibility do they
say they did most of the work or do they
give credit to teammates all of this
helps the employee to decide whether the
candidate will fit in with the other
team members another question that may
often come up how do you maintain
work/life balance and this is something
a lot of people struggle to achieve
those of you who are remote workers may
find that this question often comes up
her interviews as a work-life
distinction can often be less clear and
remote work whorls the employer is
aiming to understand the relationship
that work players in the candidates
overall life and get a view of their
priorities they can then evaluate your
attitude towards time management and
personal values and then assess whether
this aligns with the company's values so
that's just some of the questions that
you know you can consider and you can
take away and you can think about how
you might be able to weave your core
values into it so I'm just going to
quickly go on to the last slide which is
your takeaway points so just as a
takeaway I just want you to think about
know your core values if you don't know
what your core values are then do a
value exercise to work them out you can
always book a session with a career
coach to go through your results job
searching use your core values to help
filter through job descriptions
thoroughly check out the company's
website to understand their beliefs and
values think about what do you need in
the job to make you feel happy or
satisfied connections speak to any
connections who may have worked at the
company look out for warning flag that a
company may have a negative corporate
culture interviews be prepared
preparation is key this is your
opportunity to disseminate why you're a
good fit and culture at
so companies are looking at this now
rather than thinking about culture fit
sometimes you may not tick all the boxes
for a company at the time but the
question is do you have the potential to
add value to a company's culture in the
long term what can you bring to the
table that's unique so well we've come
to the end of the webinar so just going
to give you a couple of minutes to share
your thoughts do you have any Q&A and so
just thinking about and reflecting on
you know what we've just been through
just type any curious questions you may
have in the box and share your thoughts
with us so there any questions here we
have her any questions and while you
might be doing that I'll just them can
we just see the last slide I'll just put
the last slide just to let you know
about the next webinar that's going to
be coming up so yeah so the next webinar
will take place on the 2nd of March it
is with Andrea MIA and it's all about
entrepreneurial mindset and practical
steps to starting your own business
so for those of you who might be
interested in that that's going to take
place on the 2nd of March 2020 at 2:00
p.m. so any questions ah thank you very
much I'm glad you found the webinar
helpful Anna should you include your
values in your elevator pitch so a
question from Anna thank you Anna
so your question is should I include my
values in my elevator pitch and yes I
think you should do um it's very very
well thought it's your opportunity to
demonstrate to the company that you've
read about them you know so if you're
targeting you've got a target company in
mind if you're going to a networking
event um and in particular if you know
and some of the individuals who might be
attending and you know you know what
companies that they're at it's your
opportunity to be able to present
yourself and expression
yourself in your pitch in a way that
shows that you know you identifying you
know what that company's values are and
that you thought about it and that your
values are aligned so yeah it's a very
good opportunity to be able to
demonstrate that you know you thought
about it and that your values can and do
fit in with the companies that you're
approaching anyone else so thank you
very much it's very kind of you thank
you guys for joining we're coming up
towards the end we've only got a couple
of minutes left so thank you I'd like to
thank you all for joining I'd like to
thank my co-host Mira for managing the
chat room for me thank you very much any
last-minute questions or is that it from
everyone anymore thank you thank you all
much appreciated okay well if that's it
I shall give you a couple more minutes
back in your diary so that you can go
and you know do what you need to do I
thank you very much for your time cuz
everyone's time is very precious and so
just going to sort of put my face there
can you all see me hope you can still
see me thank you all for joining and
enjoy the rest of your day whatever the
time is where you are okay thank you bye
bye al